truly great film trilogies are few and
far between sure there are standouts
like Star Wars and Lord of the Rings but
besides those an unblemished trilogy is
a shockingly rare thing plenty of
franchises go straight downhill after
the opening chapter what's even worse
though is a trilogy that's held back
from perfection by a single entry it's
maddening for fans of the story being
told and more often than not if denies
fans the story structure or resolution
they desire with all that in mind here's
a look at some memorable trilogies
ruined by one movie spider-man it's hard
to overstate the massive success of Sam
Raimi's first two Spider Man films they
were crucial in creating the modern
superhero boom as we know it spider-man
and spider-man 2 showed modern audiences
that the genre could still work in the
wake of 90s bombs like Batman and Robin
watching them today it's easy to
understand why they're clear labors of
love and with the second chapter ending
on a cliffhanger for the ages it seems
that the third installment was primed
for a killer finale
unfortunately Raimi butted heads with
the studio during production of
spider-man 3 he was ultimately forced to
include popular comics villain venom
making for a bloated and convoluted
story that lacks the heart of the
previous two installments there's simply
too much going on in the campy your
moments are totally jarring against the
more serious elements where do all these
guys come from while a fourth
installment was considered and planned
Sony ultimately decided to abandon Raimi
Spidey for a rebooted model under new
director Marc Webb Blade they may not
get the respect that the x-men and
Spidey movies do but the first two blade
films are just as integral to the modern
superhero movie era while directors
Stephen Norrington and Guillermo del
Toro deserve a great deal of credit for
making the film's work as well as they
do the success really comes down to
Wesley Snipes he embodies the calm
collected cool of the character with a
performance that feels effortless but it
all went wrong in the third installment
blade Trinity set drama in a studio feud
with Snipes saw writer David s Goyer
step in as a last-minute replacement
director the result is a deeply
disappointing conclusion to a trilogy
and a character that deserves better
you've got to be kidding me
aside from a quickly cancelled TV show
we haven't seen blade on-screen since
Iron Man there are a few superhero
origin films as perfect as 2008 Iron Man
it's the film that gave us Robert Downey
jr. Tony Stark one of the all-time great
pieces of movie casting as Stark Downey
could read the phone book and make it
fun
still Iron Man 2 is something of a mess
and the only thing stopping the Iron Man
trilogy from being one of the best of
all time it's a film clearly burdened by
expectations and responsibilities it has
to introduce Black Widow to the MCU and
expand other side characters on top of
that is an ambitious but utterly
nonsensical plot involving the invention
of a new element this is the key to the
future
I'm limited by the technology of my time
but one day you'll figure this out
Iron Man too didn't tank the MCU by any
means but it's early evidence that these
films are far from infallible x-men it's
pretty standard for blockbuster films to
announce they're released eight years in
advance these days long before a
creative team has been assembled it's
crucial to remember though that that
wasn't always the case
after the first two films in the x-men
franchise were met with critical acclaim
and great financial success the
trilogy's conclusion The Last Stand was
slated for release before the script had
been finalized this turned out to be its
downfall after Bryan Singer and Matthew
Vaughn both dropped out of directing Fox
finally settled on Brett Ratner who at
that point barely had a year to make the
film multiple cast members now had
scheduling conflicts as well leading to
some strange character rewrites to
account for their absences that the film
came out at all is a small miracle and
certainly commendable in a certain light
however the end product is still pretty
lousy don't let it control you
it was such a disaster that it
effectively tanked this cinematic
incarnation of the x-men until they
reappeared for a brief swan song in
2014's Days of Future past men and black
Will Smith will always be a huge star
but he was a special kind of huge star
in the 90s any project he led was more
or less guaranteed to succeed among the
biggest of his hits is 1997 stylish
sci-fi action comedy men in black he
starred as loudmouth Agent J a brilliant
foil to his straight narrow partner
agent K played to perfection by Tommy
Lee Jones 15 years later men in black 3
arrived
wrapping up the story of agents J and K
perfectly due in no small part to a
killer performance by Josh Brolin as a
younger K why did it take 15 years for
this hit trilogy to conclude one answer
unfortunately is that the second film is
downright lousy men in black 2 feels
like a recycled version of its
predecessor with none of the charm or
surprise it may have been a box office
hit but it didn't exactly leave
audiences hungry for more
tell me something we don't know yeah
tell me something we don't so sorry
thank you there's no telling the heights
the franchise could have reached had the
second film not drop the ball so hard
for the first installment in the floor
trilogy may not be the best the MCU has
to offer but it's a solid origin story
with Shakespearean Flair thanks to
director Kenneth Branagh it almost feels
quaint a quiet little character study
about an arrogant boy who wants to be
king but isn't ready thor ragnarok on
the other hand is a nutty cosmic romp
full of laughs and unparalleled art
direction and visual design Thor the
dark world is the black sheep of the
trilogy not so much bad as it is dull it
fails to build on the sense of wonder
instilled in the first film it feels
bland and by-the-numbers and it often
looks like someone scribbled over the
first film's bright colour palette with
a grey crayon frankly it may be the
worst movie in the MCU nothing more
reassuring than realised
the world is crazier than you are the
dark world exhaust the old version of
what a thorn movie should be to the
point that Ragnarok had no choice but to
try something new ultimately it's a good
thing that Ragnarok was able to happen
even if it meant enduring a pretty bland
Thor movie first still it's hard not to
wish the Thor trilogy had maintained
more consistency the ocean' trilogy when
the right performers script and director
align a movie can feel effortlessly fun
Steven Soderbergh Vegas heist film
Ocean's eleven is one of those movies
featuring a killer cast that includes
George Clooney Brad Pitt
Matt Damon Julia Roberts and Andy Garcia
Ocean's eleven is so entertaining that
it's almost impossible to turn away from
its second sequel Ocean's thirteen is
similarly rewatchable aided greatly by
the inclusion of Al Pacino as the
villain Ocean's Twelve however very
nearly spoils the stew you can't help
but get the feeling when watching it
that Soderbergh and company wanted an
excuse to hang out in Europe and win on
to tailor the film to suit their
vacation needs everyone seems to be
having a good time but the spark present
in the first and third films is gone
throw in a genuinely bizarre subplot
involving Julia Roberts character
masquerading as Julia Roberts and you've
got a shockingly lousy film as the
direct follow-up to one of the most
entertaining movies of the century the
matrix the matrix changed the game upon
its release in 1999 even today it feels
like a revelation
it pushes genre boundaries melding
high-minded science fiction with
breathtaking action shot in the
innovative bullet time style it gives us
a cast of memorable characters and
injects themes of existentialism and
Buddhism into what could have been a cut
and dry sci-fi adventure its first
sequel The Matrix Reloaded doesn't quite
reach the heights of its predecessor but
then again what could it's still a fun
interesting action romp that expands on
the themes introduced in the first film
it all comes crashing down with the
Matrix Revolutions a bloated mess that's
too long and devoid of anything
meaningful or important the
transgressive themes of the franchise
are cast aside for more special effects
eventually over saturating the film and
very nearly the trilogy as a whole it
fails to deliver a satisfying ending to
a story its predecessors got audiences
deeply invested in and the fact that
Neos journey never got the resolution it
deserved as one of the true missed
opportunities in recent film history
here's it over
[Music]